seid ihr fertig haben wir anders es geht
los
echt sehr unter 32 spielen said ist der
im moment wichtigste film über eine
mannschaft nur dass es frauen sind das
heißt sie überhaupt nur sind halt frauen
und die bestehenden kt und clownerien
ist ein sogenannter heißt film also ein
einbruch mit clown nummer ein ganz
normales leben führen ich will nur einen
festen job ein paar neue freunde
es gab elf es gab 12 es gab 13 und das
sind jetzt acht weil frauen natürlich
diese regel beherzigen die deng xiaoping
rausgefunden hat nämlich tue so als
hättest du es nicht drauf dann hast du
es umso schlimmer darauf ins gebraucht
wird da brauchst du um 7 schmuckstücke
zu machen
sechs stunden und wenn ich dir sage du
musst nicht weniger also wir sind ja nur
achten sind ja nur frauen
von wegen banane das ist eine sehr
elegante dampf als dieser für
das gute an diesem film ist alles und
helena bonham carter
sie spielt eine unglaublich lustige
unglaublich tragische unglaublich
gebrochene unglaublich aufrichtige
unglaublich witzige unglaublich mit
geschulter regen de und wahnsinnig gute
ich glaube helena bonham carter genau
das ist was sie spielt das ist ja auch
was sie ist also haut hin
sie sitzt einmal mit einem nutella topf
nach einer schweren niederlage einer
besprechung von etwas was sie
veranstaltet hat lächelt in diesem hotel
topf rum und sagt habt ihr das gelesen
wer das geschrieben hat ein blogger wir
alten menschen kann uns mit diesem satz
wahnsinnig gut identifizieren selbst
wenn wir selber bloggen müssen und wir
müssen ja bloggen sonst gehen wir unter
gewissen dass ich ein riesending
ich bin ich sagte ich bin ganz bald
wieder da das ist mamis ganz spezielle
geschäftsreise
die regie hat gary ross gemacht aber er
lässt einfach die leute machen also gute
regie heißt ja lied voller get out of
the way und er hat sich für das dritte
entschieden was die sehr vernünftig ist
wenn ich mein cate blanchett halo 1
hathaway bitte sitzen denen sagen was
sie machen sollen
wie heißt du wirklich also dass er um
diebstahl und unrechtmäßiges an sich
bringen von beweglichen sachen geht
sollte diesen film jede und jeder gucken
die oder der jemals irgendetwas wollte
dass man ihm oder ihr vorenthalten hat
also zum beispiel in besseren job oder
ein diamanten coli oder so zeug
[Musik]
ich glaube das ist tatsächlich bestand
hat eines weltweiten trends den männern
ihre ganzen spielsachen wegzunehmen
da steckt halt gott dahinter weil so ist
er als schwarze frau
was hast du da gemacht hat ist
eingeschaltet